incredible guests and more importantly
we've raised money for two
very good causes that's not to say that
the donation links will be closing um
you please keep donating and keep moving
as long as we can
uh but we decided to just have this
final stream um
just us just game spot and chat about
the last six weeks
and we thought we'd do it under the
guise of our podcast game spot after
dark so
it's game spot after dark live which is
gonna be chatting about play for all
joining me today so we have tomorrow
hussein
michael hyam what to do could individual
greetings jacob decca this isn't
officially episode 50 but it's kind of
episode 50.
forty 49.1 point five maybe and chastity
vicenzio
oh hello everyone um
icon well six weeks six of us
uh but more importantly we have a
special seventh guest
this is like paul rudd in friends the
seventh friend
we've got eric tay the voice of god tell
you say hi
hey
yeah basically playful could not happen
without
tay uh he's been on every stream
troubleshooting and like just because
suddenly
even the last charity stream today he
was having to do mad pivots
at the 11th hour or should i say the 11
59th
hour uh we're moving quickly from
discord to zoom
and so his insight into how this whole
event
and how we managed to pull it off is
completely you know it's
necessary he he's been involved in
everything so he is involved too
uh our charity links are still open
they're both on the screen right now so
we've got black lives matter
uh bit dot ly slash gs blm
and uh direct relief so bit dot ly slash
gs dash covered
money going to two incredible causes um
but first let's just chat about
the highlights of what we've been doing
the last six weeks so this will be
encompassing not only the charity
streams but of course
press conferences we've covered games
we've got to play
um interviews that we've done so chassis
i'm going to come to you
first what have been your highlights of
the last six weeks
ah there's been so many but we did a lot
of really great charity streams
and just the outpouring of support from
the community has been so lovely
um i just want to shout out to people
who've been donating especially those
who donated multiple times on multiple
charity streams um
we love you guys thank you so much for
everything you've done
um but yeah we had a lot of great guests
and a lot of good energy and just like
it was nice to team up with some friends
of gamespot to just
hang out and um raise money for a good
cause so
i want to shout out everyone that's been
a guest on play for all for sure
but i i put together a few fun ones and
my favorites were um i mean this is just
a little selfish but i the movie trivia
was super fun and i really liked putting
that together and i got really into it
i stayed up way too late putting out uh
together questions and zooming in on
movie posters and that was a lot of fun
and uh thanks to jack pattillo for
joining us for that last one uh going
head-to-head with lucy
and lucy beating him by like uh six
points i think uh great job lucy
lucy seriously impressive
thank you with the i'm glad i'm glad
that you used the word impressive
yes weird no that impresses me
i know it was really good um also i had
a lot of fun with naomi kyle
and she did some face painting with rob
and that was hilarious they both like
tried to
paint the avengers symbol and uh it
looked like there was a poop on rob's
face
robert sang the spy skills rob sang the
spice girls and that was also a
highlight for me uh he had a deep cut he
was his favorite spice girls song was to
become one
and so naomi's like i don't remember
that one so he started singing it and i
sang with him
oh man what a time but yeah that was
that was a good one
yeah a lot of good charity streams uh
and i think for me at least your
interview with alex
uh the interview with alex garland like
you threw that together and that was
trying to make that happen
uh can you talk a little bit more about
how we got him involved
yeah um alice garland in front of
gamespot now we worked with him a couple
times now alex garland if you're not
familiar with him has
um he was the creator director behind
movies such as annihilation and ex
machina and the show devs that's on fx
on hulu
he's such an amazing creative mind and
it was really cool to get him involved
so um we had work
with um fx on devs promotion when debs
came out this year so
um we reached out to them and just asked
if alex
would be down to do some charity stuff
and and he was so like he he loves
talking about video games too so i think
he just really loves any opportunity to
talk with people about video games so he
was completely
down to do it and it turns out he has
played more
hours in animal crossing than i have
which is seriously impressive
and um he even made a flag of his
daughter's face and not using any kind
of
app or anything to like mimic the
picture he just did it
by hand and i was like wow the
dedication
but no he's great uh that was such a fun
interview
awesome before we move on to kind of
like the games and announcements and
such
from play for all uh that have been
announced during playful let's let's
just continue on with
stream highlights and what people have
enjoyed doing so
kurt what have you loved doing oh dear
i well i had the ridiculous uh
of the honor to sit in uh with tam
with the brilliant minds of remedy even
though i was
for the most part silent and dumbfounded
but uh most importantly i turned into a
monster halfway through my voice my
microphone
uh dipped out and i became i sound like
a large
giant creature man and nobody told me
tell me to tried to tell me but they
couldn't tell
me but still that's like that's a
personal thing
sitting among those dudes and being able
to sit in with those cats was
it's like hard to comprehend especially
because
max payne was like my favorite game of
all time for the longest time and i used
to like
emulate and think about that game all
the time and then just sitting there
not in the same room but in the same
virtual room as sam like was stupid for
me i
it was incredible that was amazing all
three of those cats were just so
brilliant
that was amazing also yeah that's really
about it
i feel like there's also just watching
the red dead stream
not being a part of it but just watching
that stream was one of the most amazing
moments
of this entire past six weeks jake and i
are both like we
we kind of threw a list together of uh
you know highlights and jake and i
both being on that stream have both uh
written about it and both wanted to
shout out to jake
let's talk a little bit about red dead
man yeah
that was like i it was
it was almost a dream i mean it was
pretty much a dream come true like just
sitting there and playing
red dead with those guys and hearing uh
you know roger clark or arthur morgan
like being like let's ride
jake let's ride let's see and stuff like
that was just like
absolutely blowing my mind or like uh
uh the duchess voice actor was like i
know this whole map like the back of my
hand i don't need a map
and we're following him from like town
to town and he did
man like he has incredible amount of
knowledge like
every time i'd open the map he'd be like
oh yeah i don't need that and i'm like i
know i do though
and i claimed to be a fan but that was
unreal
that that was something real yeah you
got so many
like great donations too and it was
really good to see
that like there was a bunch of rock star
and red dead fans in the chat too that
were
donating and even some who'd like join
our game and show up occasionally you
know
starting a little fight that we didn't
need but a lot of them were just like
it was weird it was like we were like
with celebrities
in the game because like we'd go to a
place and stop for a bit and all these
characters would gather around us
and just watch and be like i don't
really know what's happening
it was really surreal
i think because we had a couple of zoom
calls with them ahead of time to
you know make sure that all the tech
stuff was set up and that they were
could get into
uh discord okay and that you know we
could all be in a posse together
but the first time like you said when
you hear them say your name
but obviously they have they put on some
affectation
when they are voicing the characters but
honestly like roger clark and
ben byron ben davis and um alex mckenna
they all
just sound like they're characters and
so
you know hearing hearing dutch say all
right lucy let's ride i'm like oh my
gosh
okay yes please but yeah and the
community was so nice and
when they were leaving messages it was
kind of incredible to see
the messages they were leaving like i
have i've had a really hard time you
know someone died and i threw myself
into red dead and that
um helped me and so you know i'm
donating money to give back and
there was so many messages like that and
i think out of all the streams that
we've done that was the one that really
kind of
you know the whole thing about playful
is you know gaming
can help people and we've been raising
money for two
excellent causes but at the same time
you kind of have that
the more human one-on-one moments of
just like
these stories about how gaming does
directly impact people
emotionally and so i think the red dead
stream for me was the best illustration
of that
um and it was a lot of fun and also yeah
yeah friends of gavin
right at the beginning like this guy
showed up and was griefing us
and i was like i must be you know
driscoll and immediately alex was like
i'll kill every last one of them oh
driscolls and i was like oh my god this
is really happening
that was super cool uh tam you have also
done a lot of charity streams what's
been
uh your fave oh there's so much of it
but
during that red dead stream i was very
surprised to learn that roger
knows i exist i was like he loves you
he's great on twitter
i was like oh [ __ ] people are actually
looking at the twitter i should
actually uh now i'm very conscious of
the fact that roger is there
potentially looking at my tweets i'm
just like i need to behave myself
can't think about that cause i think
about that yeah well arthur morgan
can't be mad at me wait you could you
could do your arthur to morgan tweet
again
morgan yeah but yeah there was like so
much stuff that
i really love so i'm just gonna kind of
rattle through him
i think the first one i want to start
with like this is in no particular order
it's just highlights that came to my
mind like the last podcast streams that
we did
that was unreal like so the last podcast
on the left that
is a podcast that i'm a huge fan of lucy
i know is a huge fan of
um and have been a fan of for a lot of
years so there was a period when i
wasn't working in the industry it was
after my last job i got made redundant
and there was stuff happening in the
games industry that made me feel like
this isn't what gay this is not what i
got into it for
like this is it's turned into something
that i don't like and i was worried
about
you know it made me think about what
would happen if this all fell apart
would i still be able to do a normal job
so i was like you know what i'm going to
go and do a normal job for a bit
and so i joined london underground the
transport service there and i worked
a shift i did a shift job like early
mornings late nights and
standing in the cold getting abused by
uh public
members of the public that kind of stuff
and i always listen to that podcast to
get me through it every day like i was
listening to it every single day and
just it's a true crime podcast
so that that podcast on the team has
been a huge part of my life for ages
and then at the start of this whole
production i remember it was like me
lucy chastity and we were just like
let's just ask people
like the worst that can happen is
they'll say no but let's just like
whoever we want anyone that comes to
mind let's just try
and we didn't expect so many people to
say yes no we expected most
we sent out a lot of emails and requests
and we thought most of them are going to
get
shut down and we'll have a few in
between that we can
you know have in between our own uh
streams of playing games
and one of them was the last podcast
crew and i emailed them
i dm'd one of them on twitter and it was
an
almost instant yes and i remember
sending lucy a message as being like
henry said yes and like that was our day
done like we were freaking out
and then and then like henry was like
henry zabrowski who's like
um one of the cast members an incredibly
funny guy and
huge fan of his and he was like yes and
then we started an email chain to get it
together and he was well up for it all
the time and then he was like let me get
marcus in marcus is another guy from the
podcast
and then we got to talk to marcus and
marcus was like i want to do my own
stream
like on my own i want to play dark souls
and we were like oh [ __ ] he wants to not
only
his own stream
we're both of them together and it was
just so much fun it's like one of those
really chill streams that was a lot of
fun
um so that was a highlight and then like
there's others that like jesus having
him
and
yeah just another person that i'm a huge
fan of as a bloodborne streamer and
another one that i thought he probably
won't he probably won't like he's not
going to do this for us and he was so
keen and he was so nice about it and
and like his stream was fascinating and
his community came in and just dropped
donations like non-stop and it was
seeing our two communities kind of vibe
and and kind of like
find that you know they have a lot in
common that was amazing and that stream
is still incredible
and then it was the same my favorite
moment from that stream though i just
want to shout out is when he was
fighting
ludwig and he was like hold on i'm gonna
adjust the sound right now
mid-fight brings up the pause menu
cranks up the music and then goes back
and kills them and i was
like what about their jaw open what a
flex
thing it was it was incredible um
and then like other people like superior
patchwolf is a a youtuber that does
anime and pop culture that i really love
and
i emailed him and it was it was like
this guy's not gonna care
and he was like oh i love gamespot i've
been following you guys forever i'm a
huge fan of yours and i was like
what this is mad and then he came on and
we played what remains of edith finch
for the first time
and you could see his mind racing and
like see the way he
he's so thoughtful about the way he
deconstructs and analyzes content and
you could see him doing it on the fly
and
enjoying the game um that was amazing
and then we had rkg yesterday
and we played geoguessr and we started
with a zero meter guess
and that's like the holy grail of geo
guesser
and then we ended in wales which is
gav's home you know and it was that was
amazing
um and then we had chris bratt from
uh people make games all on in the uk
who's amazing he's actually in the chat
now and he was like great
great work and they played a fun game um
game trivia with rob that was ridiculous
and fun
it's the one trivia one that i was
actually decent at
i'm joe biden i'm joe biden but like
that one was good because like yeah
i i got some like ridiculous the gta 5
guess which was just like
something lesbian noise unbelievable it
was just a dog boxing and a dog walking
and i was like that's a gta dog i know
that dog
or rob had a ship sound and i was like
halo and he's like god dang it
yeah yeah um but yeah and then like
there was the tim sweeney interview
which was the first thing that we
did which was like i was terrified of
that interview like i was
all the interviews that i do like i have
this
like i can't get rid of it but it's just
like anxious anxiety fight or flight
response to every single interview i do
and that one was really bad
so like going into doing that interview
i was just terrified
it was great i was gonna say your
anxiety was bad but the interview was
incredible yeah
you got to talk about the ball that it
was incredible i i ever after i do every
interview people i was like how was it
i'm like i got
i ain't got a clue man because i was
just so like
sweating buckets the entire time but
like they
he it was fun like tim sweeney was way
more chilled i think that's the one
time i think that that interview what
i'm proud of in hindsight is
tim sweeney and kim library just looking
like humans like goofing around
talking about epic but also like how
much they love popeyes holding up that
weird electric ball thing
and you know just messing around and so
that was a lot of fun
um and then the other thing that i just
like super proud of is the amazing team
effort like
to get emotional not to get emotional
but like
the amount of work that people have put
into this is
unreal like cassidy lucy kind of
the effort in kind of putting it all
together and arranging that stuff was
ridiculous
haim's done an unbelievable amount of
interviews so is kurt
um and every single one of them are like
bangers and
jake has been conducting interviews as
well and like working on tech in the
background and it's been
ridiculous and jean-luc's been helping
with him uh him with that and doing that
stuff
tay is just like unreal uh how good he
is at his job
and constantly fixing things as they
break non-stop
um you know richie in every moderate
every single stream
just you know moderating and shouting
out things and then doing highlights and
and the social team you know ashley eric
will everyone promo team
josh kind of like you know getting it
all done it was it's been a massive
effort um persia did a bunch of stuff
and like she even
did a stream for her birthday and raised
like 120 and donated all that to
to the charity and it's been like when
we came into this i remember we wanted
to show like lucy said
that games can be used as a force for
good and i think we did that as a team
like
we didn't we didn't want it to be just
like a half-baked e3 replacement
um because we we all knew that it wasn't
going to be an e3 replacement you can't
get those kind of like
banging announcements in this day and
age but
we wanted to instead try and take that
energy and put it into something
useful and help the world out a bit and
i
i think i personally feel proud that we
did do that and i think that everyone
else should feel proud that we did that
yeah i think absolutely that's how
everyone feels
a little tired definitely but everyone's
very very proud of everything dude
especially youth
too you guys have done so many live
streams i can't
believe you guys are functioning at this
point it's a lot of makeup and a ring
light
i also want to shout out like a couple
of people like i don't want to
i don't want to like say you know any
anyone's donations are more valuable
than ever but
matt hocking noah's igbo like uh
jay armstrong there's a few people who
showed up so
frequently and like daniel moreno our
discord
community just watching and commenting
and
just like raising awareness those folks
were i swear they were in every single
stream and some of them
are in ridiculous time zones brandon
hernandez is another one who was
always in our our chat just chatting um
just a bunch of people around the clock
from our community i think this has been
really great in connecting our community
as well
i think we can all safely say like the
gamespot community is vast
and to a point when it gets that big you
almost lose touch
with them like you're not as intimate
with them but this this
experience as it feels like to me like
we've reconnected with our community in
a big way and
we've been able to kind of understand
the value of speaking to our of our you
know
readers viewers that kind of stuff way
more and we've been given avenues to do
it and i'm encouraged to do it again so
that's been
huge yeah just to jump off that quickly
like anyone who's watching now like we
have a gamespot discord where there's
lots of
lots of fans of gamespot and people who
like to play games in there and if
you're interested in joining you can
uh dm any one of us on twitter and we'll
make sure to get you in because
like timur was saying like that has been
such a good place for
fans and gamers and whatnot to connect
over games they like
and even this whole play for all stream
it was nice having
uh that group of people there um to
watch they were doing watch parties
yeah we were doing that as well which is
really cool
so if you're watching you're not part of
it yet please please message one of us
we'd love to have you in there
yeah michael i'm gonna come to you next
what have been some of your highlights
oh
[ __ ] oh man you have been like
on the editorial side holding it down
like so many interviews every time i'm
in like
playful host slack it's you know you and
kurt mostly taking
so many interviews and being so busy
writing stuff up
reviewing stuff all at the same time so
yeah it's it's been a lot it's been a
lot of work but
i mean i think that uh it really helped
that
we can centralize or we were able to
centralize like
this is the thing that we are working
for uh because it's
it's pretty easy to get lost in all of
the tasks that you need to do and like
keeping up with like embargo [ __ ] like
there's just so many yo there's so many
moving parts i'm like hitting up matt
spinelli on slack like yo can you
do me a big solid and check to see if my
asana is straight and all that stuff
make sure all these dates are aligned
because i mean like like tam said it's
it's a team effort and like my
experience
extends to other people who are also
coordinating
chasing down email threads and making
sure things are on time making sure like
because i've been doing a lot of
developer interviews with jake and john
luke on the technical side
and we're using different programs
everyone we're contacting all these
developers are contacting are like
yo you got a webcam is your audio good
like what time zone you're in like doing
the whole
remote interviewing thing i think we
were able to get to a point where
it was very uh it was almost automatic
but getting to that point was
was kind of hard and then trying to
adjust your own home life
to be able to execute that stuff at a
serviceable level because like honestly
like i was working off a damn webcam for
most of the time
and i got i got my microphone stacked on
four books to make sure it's up to
my mouth so it's very makeshift but i
think that when i look back on the
things that we're able to produce
we're still pretty much i feel like
we're still pretty much hitting the same
level of content that we would have
otherwise
i think we don't have the big stage we
don't got hundreds of
people with passing by foot traffic of
e3 but
uh the spirit is still there and to be a
part of that is is really big because
you know there's so many people involved
and just to be one of them
is pretty dope uh yeah and
there's there's some times i got to
while out and do my thing like
uh particularly i think my favorite one
was the yakuza
like a dragon interview because uh
obviously yakuza means a lot to me and
then
last year i was able to do one on
judgement with uh toshi or nagoshi but
obviously like
uh we weren't able to get him but i was
able to talk about localization with
scott strickard who i've been trying to
get a hold of for a very long time
i'm in contact with with him as the
yakuza games come
out but to finally have something i've
been talking to him a lot be like yo
when we
want to do this uh talk about
localization make some make some content
out of that because it's so fascinating
to me
and then to incorporate that with play
for all was like yes
i finally did something on it uh so that
was that felt really cool
game i'm very very excited about uh that
was
that was probably the highlight of like
and but i've done like so many
interviews that
the thing too is that you don't just hop
on a call and be like all right
let's get to some questions like there's
a lot of
you don't want to look like a dumb ass
on on these videos because it's going to
show right
um so there's a lot of prep that goes
into
these interviews like for games that
like i might have touched before but i
didn't necessarily play many hours
of but i need to be able to
provide the context provide the
questions that are actually going to
give
insight rather than like hey tell me
about the guns that you have in
borderlands 3 like
there's so much more to that and then so
the ability to quickly contextualize and
understand different games different
genres
week on almost daily basis has been i'm
like damn
oh damn y'all y'all game spot getting
your money's worth with me
you know the vibes uh but yeah that's
that was it was a ton of fun that that's
like the
my favorite thing that i like doing that
stuff it's a lot
of work that goes into it to like do it
well
um you want to be better than good
uh you want to be great at it but it
takes work to get there and i feel like
all of us who have been putting in the
work have been able to reach that level
so it's it's i'm really proud to be a
part of that
uh and i think that's a highlight to me
i mean we'll talk about uh
some games and specific event moments
that uh that really stuck out to us
uh because i got a lot to share but on
my end like
i think at some point you will you want
to be like proud of the work that you do
and this is
this is one of those moments where i'm
like damn six weeks
six weeks is a long-ass time and you
have to be on point because there's like
some weeks of slack it's like hey we got
this interview got this this this lined
up we got the stream lined up
all right who's willing and ready uh
it's always that it was always that uh
who's willing and ready to go today
tomorrow uh the next day so
yes we done did it uh still
still some more work to do but you know
what we've kind of reached the
we can cr the cruise a little bit more
now so um
yeah so we have a huge donation from
our good friend nawaz iqbal who just
gave a hundred and fifty dollars
thank you 19 direct relief thank you so
much nawaz
nawaz wrote hey guys just want to thank
everyone at gamespot for all your hard
work and putting
play for all event together the past six
weeks has been so much fun
congrats on raising so much money for
two incredible causes you love to see it
you do love it you totally do
thank you so much um and more we've got
the uh
as mentioned before um our very own
persia
uh raised 120 and she split that amongst
both causes so sixty dollars towards
black lives matter sixty dollars towards
covenanting relief thank you so much
persia
um ten dollars from matt hawking again
matt thank you oh my goodness matt
you're amazing
and matt wrote nice work everyone and
then our buddy jake baldino
coming through two hundred dollars from
jake baldino oh
hey thank you thank you jake holy [ __ ]
shout out to jake from jake jake jake is
one of the nicest people
history he is like incredible he's so
talented and humble and he was on a
couple of our streams
again he and i played portal 2 together
and i'm sure he won't mind me saying
this
we're both bad at paul too but honestly
it was so much fun
he is one of the nicest guys and
uh so talented he's a trivia winner too
yeah he looks very good at it
he did uh not to plug jake uh but he did
a video on
um batman begins the other day and it's
honestly it's
it's so good it's so good and i was like
you're right you're wrong
because dark knight is better but you're
right
what is jake baldino doing he he also he
just gave two hundred dollars to covet
and then i go to the black lives matter
page and he's
given five hundred dollars
[Music]
hey see this is this is what we were
literally just saying he's the one of
the kindest nicest people
around like incredible thank you wow
jake
he's on he's on twitter flood him with
thank yous
he's at jake baldino and go subscribe
yeah go
on youtube uh both on game ranks and his
personal channel
because he produces some really great
stuff and he's great
incredible and also nawaz thank you
again nawaz iqbal 150
to black lives matter also so nawaz came
through
again so 150 dollars to each cause
just now thank you so much so much thank
you
you guys yeah like that's that's what
we're talking about yeah
that's what we're talking about exactly
that
uh it's been genuinely like i think one
of the things that
you're always fearful of when you run a
charity event is that no one's gonna
tune in no one's gonna donate but
we've had some just they're all
incredible eggs
and thank you all for tuning in and
donating and like the money's going to
such
great causes and i mean originally when
we were planning
play for all you know it was gonna be
just covered relief and then
we realized that in good faith we could
not run an event if we weren't going to
be
you know showing support for and raising
money for black lives matter
and i'm like that decision came through
like
unanimously and it was literally the day
before
wasn't it yeah it was it was the day
before it was like
on a sunday right and then they started
monday i was we were
we were playing overwatch yeah
like i was i was protesting
i was i was in the streets you know and
i was getting i was getting down with uh
some folks were bumping some uh mac dre
and e40 on the street so you know we you
know
we're we're trying to square up uh
against the police out the streets in
oakland but you know we're also going to
have a good time
everyone's wearing masks uh too so we
kept it safe but yeah i got a slack
message at like 9 30 and said yo
uh are you down to beyond because i was
not scheduled to be on as well so
but the pivot happened uh for good
reason
i'm glad it happened and props to making
the shift
so fast uh but it was also kind of like
uh like you need to mentally prepare
yourself for that that sort of thing um
and yeah it was the live stream was
incredible you guys all
killed it yeah it was handling it so
well
yeah and then we jumped straight into
giant bomb and it's like
yeah that's that's another big community
that
you need to communicate too because then
they carry the stream and all that but
i think it was it's for the best
obviously and
i hope that there's the larger takeaway
is that
yes we were able to support a great
cause but i said that i said this in the
six weeks ago when we launched this
thing was that um
it's something that needs to keep going
you know as much as donations help
that can't be the end i guess i guess i
can say i'll say this now
now that we're on the topic but uh the
reason why we're supporting black lives
matter and the movement
is because uh we also want to
make people aware that it's not just
donations not just money you need to
educate yourselves on these
sorts of things we've spoke to this many
times but keep that in mind as you move
as you're moving forward
be conscious of the systems that are at
play the systemic racism that
people face and if you're not uh of that
group if you're not black
uh if you're not uh like
that's something that you need to you
need to learn you need to at least learn
those
about those experiences so you
understand you can sympathize
and realize that you know there's a lot
more work that needs to be done on the
streets
uh there's there's a lot more effort it
doesn't end here but
it's a start and i'm proud to be part of
it and i'm proud to be carrying on
that that fight uh as
you know the best way that i can in my
personal life and i hope that message
carries on to everyone else
who's been tuning in and uh donating as
well i i'm trying to figure out the best
way to say
this but like i feel like this says this
whole event and
a kind of like collective reaction to it
has been like an identity defining
moment
for gamespot like as as it currently
stands
like we're a team that works for a
website that has existed for a really
long time
and for a lot of times that time like
people come
in and out leadership changes staff
members change
and it's almost like a relay race where
we pick up where someone left off
and carry on moving forward and over
time the kind of processes and the tone
and
what we speak about kind of dilutes and
becomes one
like you don't you don't have an era of
of you know this is the era of
you know this this type of game spot
that type of game sport and this felt
like a moment where
the team is incredibly diverse we're
incredibly
we try our best to be on top of issues
social issues racial issues
issues you know that are close to our
heart um
and this felt like the first time where
we really kicked open a door and came
out and said this is what this current
generation of gamespot is about
we love video games we love movies we
love tv we love entertainment we love
covering that stuff we love making
content around that stuff
but we are also people and we care about
the world we care about our audience we
care about
you know the issues that people face and
i feel like this is the first time we've
actually like stood on a platform and
shouted that so it was crystal clear
and the amazing thing that is like like
michael
michael ohio was saying there it's the
first it feels like the first step in
something that we now feel confident and
comfortable in going forward and trying
our best to maintain
and the amazing thing about that is
we've also had our community respond
like we've had people who know us
and watch our stuff over there in the
industry or out in the industry
kind of reciprocate that and that's just
such a good feeling having people like
you know jake and nawaz and
jacob mccoy and various other members of
our community the you know
there's members from the discord
community on site
um people who watch streams kind of
reciprocate that and say that they agree
and they feel good about that it's been
so uplifting so
as tired as we all are this has been an
incredible like energizing process as
well
like we feel good about it and like
everyone
on twitter keeps saying you know keep
that energy up going forward
this is this is something that will kind
of like feels empowering to us because
we feel like we can keep that energy up
we've made our stances clear we've shown
that we care about the stuff and we're
willing to go the extra mile
to make sure that others know that we're
doing you know others know that we will
support them when they need us
so it is maybe it sounds a bit high for
looting and a bit
grandiose but i feel like the last six
weeks was when gamespot became more than
just a video games website
it became like a force for you know
championing
voices that need it within video games
industry
and the world at large beyond just
you know video games we all step in and
do our best to support causes when
necessary
and i think that's something that's
incredibly proud we should be incredibly
proud of
yeah i i i agree obviously uh
and uh is is really nice to you know be
able to
for example like um you know i i
i feel more i've been shy about certain
saying certain things in the content
that i produce
but now it's kind of like you know what
there's no reason to be shy
like whether it was like backlash or
whatever it's like nah [ __ ] that [ __ ]
like
uh this is this is only gonna work if we
use our voices the way we want to
so i think in that regard moving forward
it's it's going to be i guess more
comfortable to be vocal about certain
things
i think another thing to keep in mind
though like as the broader
games industry like gamespot has a
space in it uh and it's it's been it's
been
a while to call that my job to operate
within this space
but i think that the in light of when we
started play for all i think it was
there's also a clear indication that the
game's
wider game space still has a lot of work
to do in terms of
inclusion uh and elevating minority
voices
black voices trans voices and all people
who cover
all sorts of uh different backgrounds um
like i'm
i'm happy with the progress um but of
course
it's progress it's not the end point
that we want to get to so
i think that you know anyone who
operates in this industry needs to be
very conscious
that if you are not a person of color
that if you are not black
that you will be extra conscious of
your place in the industry and how you
can include others
moving forward i'm confident that
the wider games industry and us too can
continue to improve on that uh as
we move forward so you know it's it was
a wake-up call
and you know i think generally i think
that for our spaces uh things are
looking up
yeah yeah i completely agree yeah
so before we move on to the games i
think there's one more person who we
definitely need to hear from
voice of god eric tay uh
how have the last six weeks been for you
what are kind of
stressful i'd imagine very busy but like
overall
how has the event gone compared to
running something like e3
um and more importantly what you're
going to do with your time off
afterwards mate
because you deserve it
okay it says you're a mutator mute
[Laughter]
then no no audio you're in the car
you're in the zoom goal
just realized he's muted i just hate to
see it
see this is what we're saying this is
the kind of thing jay has to deal with
it run it back yeah he fixes problems as
they happen
we've been recording this zoom call so
we can clip that out
wait till you're coming back hey come
back come back
we can hit you but no one in the
audience but no one else
[Laughter]
okay okay
no no are you serious
all right all right well okay first off
he has a baby in his arms which
in and of itself is now it works but now
you hear me twice
no once no we hear you once okay i mean
on the zumko
i hear myself twice or i hear myself
this is not a great
take three take three ten
can they hear you can they hear them
they should be able to hear it this time
ant-man says maybe the baby muted him
[Laughter]
i'm gonna wait for it before i mean this
is the last big
you know stream and they can have this
is this is we made it this far
sorry the audio quality is not going to
be good because it's coming from my
webcam because
this mic apparently doesn't work um
but again this is awkward thank you to
everyone
who did all this stuff uh planning and
really i just my biggest thing is making
sure that john luke gets a shout out for
helping me
um because he helped me problem solve
when my one brain can do it anymore and
then this guy
was a troublemaker so yeah i'm gonna do
with my time later is spend more time
with him obviously
i did tell chris and rob before we
started this that i
you know i wanted to have an e3 baby so
i could like
sorry i'll produce it he came early
so i bartered with my wife and told her
that like i'm gonna help them through e3
we'll now play for all because e3
obviously didn't happen
um but it's been great like grateful to
the community like you guys said there's
so many highlights and things um i feel
like i've
been talking for a while even though
really i haven't because i did the same
speech like three times
um but no i'm just grateful that
everyone that we work with i'm grateful
that we have the platform to do what we
do
i'm grateful that my wife is laughing at
me in my back in the background
but yeah thank you to everyone who's
donated thank you to all the guests
who have been on the streams thanks for
all the communities who have
come and joined in with us too uh
to kind of like merge and bridge
communities you know last podcast
brianna white um that red dead stream
was amazing
all the i had a lot of fun with a lot of
the trivia just like being behind the
scenes i always wanted to answer
i'm like come on thank you for helping
me with that
i know um but yeah i don't want to take
up too much more time so
just happy that i i've said this as a
joke
i'm happy that it's over but probably
you know come next week we're going to
be a little sad that like you know what
yeah the great thing we did for six
weeks that was tiring and
all that is now over and it's weird you
know um
it really it reminded me of kind of
being back in the office a bit more
because when we were working from home
you would just meet people at least talk
to people within the under the context
of uh
zoom meetings right whereas with this
you know you get to relax with people
and just
have a laugh and so it's been really
nice and yeah just chatting with
everyone
you mentioned jean-luc but i do want to
say like there's so many people
like if if any of us you know our
teammates and colleagues are watching
like i'm sure we can't name everyone but
it's incredibly appreciated like people
like jean-luc
just toiling away in the background like
ben janka
saved us on many many occasions like
just other video editors
all the video it is like picked up the
interviews afterwards
max is there like this
yeah david almighty dave jewett was
there um chris morris did
amazing stuff adam mason absolutely
pieced out us asap
to raise a child he had a child yeah
shout out to him but then like on the
editorial side chris pereira like
helping with all the kind of like
editorial appointments and that kind of
stuff
then like the actual editorial team
itself taking the stuff that we're doing
and writing stuff around it and then
breaking things out you know
that's you know various people kevin
steve
um jordan eddie you know
jeremy every single member of the team
like chloe on seo helping out
chris also doing seo eric you know
sam's on social i already mentioned like
ashley and
william and stuff kelly doing so like
kelly's been doing reviews on top of
coming into you know streams whenever we
could get her in
just an incredible team-wide effort
that's
i'm sure we're missing people there's
people who are working like i'm nail
crew boys
thumbnails thumbnails
i mean that stuff is it's i even had to
make a thumbnail
once but it's like it's all it's an
all-encompassing work that
every single one of us is contributing
to this we're taking precedence we're
taking a stance on stuff while also
doing our normal day jobs
and you know some of us are not getting
lunches but it's all
in part of what it is we're trying to
say and do and as i just want to echo
like what everyone said
michael and tam that you know like it
does
for me feel uh like a step in a
direction that i
did not anticipate would happen working
at a place like this and
uh it's made me more comfortable and
aware
of where i am and what i can do
with this platform and these people who
are all on the same page
uh [ __ ] great team i just had this
you thought about not sweating there i
know but i was like i have to
yeah i know it's fine and plus it's like
a second language to me you know how
hard it is for me to not
i know i know it's horrible i haven't
sworn i haven't sworn in interviews
i've kept it cool there proud of you
thank you so much
we've talked about kind of the cherry
side of it um
you know we're not gonna go on for too
much longer but i think obviously it's
super important to talk about
the games that have been announced you
know the best interviews that we've had
so let's quickly go around the
go around the zoom
zoom around did you just come up with
that
i have i have trialed that joke before
but this is the first time i've said it
on a live stream uh let's go around and
talk about kind of the big
you know i think sony e3 2015 will
always be
the absolute pinnacle of like this is
like the e3 excitement
for me but i think sony's summer
press conference you know the ps5 press
conference was hitting those high to me
i was really excited about that
and it's wild that e3 doesn't exist in a
year when new consoles are coming
uh obviously we're yet to see you know
ubisoft's gonna be on sunday
we've had ea but microsoft haven't
really you know it's their turn next uh
closer to the end of the month and so
based on what we've seen over the last
six weeks or so
let's pick out some highlights chassis
i'm going to go to you first
uh yeah ps5 was definitely a big
highlight for me
um especially just kind of kicking off
with spider-man miles morales i was so
excited about that i cannot wait to be
miles
and swing around and just have a similar
um
play style to the spider-man game on ps4
because i loved that game um
just i'm really excited to play that and
dig into that on ps5
so i i was already gonna get a ps5 so
now i'm definitely getting a ps5
um i also stray the cat
game oh my god i'm so excited that cats
are
having a year in 2020 with all these
gaming announcements and just popping up
in trailers but especially stray
um as playing as a lead character as a
cat shout out to sushi what's
up to sushi is sushi alive
like she's she's been there
she's cropped out of my she's cropped
out of my frame but she's very cozy
wozzy
sushi's my cat by the way and then
throughout almost every live stream
and interview she's been sleeping on the
couch right here if you can see a little
bit of her furs
i see that that foot just like that next
she's real cozy woesy and then uh but
yeah
uh she's been a part of the live streams
a lot of fans
love loved her in the chat so very
very happy that she's got fans but yeah
sushi's great
and uh the other highlight for me in
terms of game announcements was new
pokemon snap
um thank you tim for shooting videos of
me um
in a snorlax onesie prepping for pokemon
snap
yeah honestly it felt inappropriate that
i did that save state but
in a way i'm almost it worked i'm so
glad that like that was like i was like
we need to have chastity and that's like
i cannot
not so i'm so glad you two put that
together if you guys haven't seen that
maybe
maybe i'll try and link that uh it's my
pin tweet
you can just check it out it's it's
chessy's glowing most identifying moment
so it's amazing
uh kit what about you death loop
like i am so excited for that game like
not only do i absolutely just
adore everything arcane does but death
loop
was hitting just from that trailer
reveal hit on
this like 60s ultra violent
funkadelic james bond thing with some of
the coolest
like characters as like front and center
i've seen in a video game in a long time
and
i already was going to get cons i'm like
i'm saving up money to get consoles day
one like that's that's important to me
but knowing that's a ps5 exclusive it
was like i
it's all over like i cannot wait for
that game and then
on top that being able to interview them
was just incredible so that opportunity
i jumped on the opportunity as quickly
as possible and
i know lucy i i think everyone here is
are huge arcane fans
so i immediately was like uh lucy's
probably gonna want to do that because
it's the art director of dishonored but
i'm sure tam's gonna want to
but i'm very very stealthy boys am i
still people that's the thing that
interview was at 8 am
and i was like i was ready for it that's
the thing you wake up at life
but no i so it's funny you said it as
well yeah
yeah i almost felt kind of i almost felt
kind of guilty sorry about that i don't
feel guilty but no like
you you put in the work man you did you
did yeah you did good i got my arcane
interview though because i interviewed
raphael antonio i don't know
so i'm good i'm covered for arcane
still but yeah well it's nonetheless
like i'm so glad that i was able to jump
on that
and thank you guys for giving me that
opportunity to do it also
god there's so much to talk about that
odd world reveal those like odd world
and death over the two games i'm most
excited about probably from that sony
reveal like that was like the crowning
thing that happened i think for all of
us
but the moment in which lucy
hands a mug through space and time
into tam's hands without like without
any like
it was so serendipitous it was just
you gotta pull up the clip i think i
prepared a clip yeah
i think about this daily and this is
like here it is
there it is look oh my god
it's telling of tam and lucy's like
friendship and all of this that like
this like
this this this thing this this ominous
thing that happened it's incredible i
love it so that was like
more than more than any game reveal that
blew my mind
all right jake uh i mean i'm gonna have
to go
cyberpunk having played that game uh
was like i i still kind of don't believe
that i got to play that game for four
hours
and partly it kind of felt like a dream
because i was playing it in my house on
my pc
for like four hours like i like i don't
know ate some breakfast and sat down at
the computer and just played cyberpunk
and now i can't play cyberpunk
so like it it's kind of breaking my
brain in a sense
yeah yeah finally being able to like get
hands-on with that game
see what the world's about and just kind
of explore that world like
it's strange because i feel like i
haven't really developed any thoughts on
it yet like any like really i don't know
i guess like
solid thoughts on the game but it's
because i only played like
four of you know four hours of a game
that could be
hundreds it could be like a hundred
hours or so so so it's hard to say in
that sense but like i don't know
that veil of mystery has finally been
lifted and
like it it was so cool to play
definitely like
a highlight and two just like the tech
behind it like using nvidia
uh nvidia now i think is what it's
called geforce now
geforce now that's close enough yeah
michael knows
um like using that was really impressive
i imagine
i probably used about 30 gigs in that 30
gigs of data in that like four hours i
spent with it but like still it was
super impressive to
play a game like that over the cloud but
yeah there's so much to talk about with
cyberpunk and we've got a ton of videos
about it up right now so if you're
curious about that four hour session
definitely check those out because i
know we're
we're short on time but yeah it i it has
to be cyberpunk definitely check them
out
michael yo um so
there's like there are a lot of big game
reveals
and i usually have like tempered
expectations like i don't get
a hell of hype for things usually unless
it's like
the very specific things like it's not
final fantasy 14 if it's not persona
it's not yakuza
i'm not jumping out of my seat uh that's
not to say i don't like games
but it's just more like oh okay uh it's
cool to see that thing
um and then so like the the ps5 reveal
was fun
i think i had a lot of fun uh doing that
because uh
tam and lucy my homies obviously uh but
it's also like
a an opportunity to kind of deconstruct
what we're seeing in games like
for example like horizon forbidden west
is something that i'm
i'm actually excited about but i'm also
like hey there's a lot of work that
needs to be done with some of the native
imagery that you're using and i
like being able to kind of express that
and kind of
think back to my experience with verizon
zero dawn how it relates to
what i'm expecting out of forbidden west
those are things that i really enjoy
doing and i think that are important
when we do talk about these games uh
especially as we
become more conscious of uh where they
come and the things that they're trying
to say in them
so that is one game that i'm uh looking
forward to
uh because of various perspectives uh
but man
when when when atlas dropped so for
example when atlas dropped persona 4
golden on pc
i lost my goddamn mind of course
of course i knew beforehand obviously
persona 4
is one of my favorite games of all time
it was my favorite game
of all time until i played persona 5
royal uh so
when i got the news beforehand that has
come to pc i'm like y'all y'all are
messing with me
he's messing with me this is not real
and then it was like oh it's true and
here's a code
to play it before reveal i'm like i'm
sitting there playing p4g on my pc and
like tears listening to the soundtrack
you know one night when i was uh like
capturing for because i did a whole
piece on like how well does it translate
to pc it turns out it
translates extremely well um but one
night i was just like sitting there i
was like
i got like an empty bottle e and j i was
drinking out this thing and i was just
like sitting there
uh listening to signs of love as as i'm
just chilling there with
with dojima i'm like damn i can't
believe this
is happening of course i got i got a
vita with the game on it but i'm playing
this [ __ ] and like
crisp 1080p with anti-aliasing at
120 frames per second boy oh my god
yeah nothing like getting excited about
a 12 year old game ported to pc because
that is my highlight
uh game reveal and launch for during
this
play for all window but i think uh on a
more serious note i think that
i want to give a shout out to the
guerrilla collective uh for their black
voices and gaming stream
because that was also a a a sudden pivot
for
guerrilla collective which they took an
entire day to highlight
black game developers that was very
important
because i saw so many things that i
didn't even know about and i tried to
keep up with
what a lot of independent developers are
doing what a lot of
bipoc folks are doing in the game space
but to have a whole stream where it's
like yo let's just celebrate what we're
working on
that was very important i got to see uh
my friend my good friend davion goodin
who's working on she dreams elsewhere
which is a game that i am absolutely
excited about i saw it at pax earlier
this year before we got locked down
i got to chop it up with him play his
game and it
is right up my alley because it's
persona
mixed with undertale i've talked about
it before but to see
that game like get a platform it
deserves
and for him to like talk through it was
i was like okay this is this is
this is dope i like this and also with
gorilla collective i'll give a special
shout out another one
to my guy justin woodward so justin
woodward
uh he runs also the indie mix that we uh
collaborate with every time gdc rolls
around every time we go to conventions
but justin woodward he is from my
hometown of southeast san diego so we
are from the same hood and when we got
to chop it up
at gdc a couple years back i didn't know
and i was like
holy [ __ ] this dude grew up on the same
block as me
and he's like out here doing things like
gorilla collective making his own games
doing any mix
so special shout out to justin woodward
uh see him running that show
yeah we actually he's the real mvp like
i've worked with him for a long time now
with e3 and the indie mix and stuff
and like he is like we had one year i
think it was actually last year where uh
when e3 was cracking down on badges like
originally
i don't even know if i'm allowed to say
this but like to get independent
developers into e3
on our stage we'd have to like have them
borrow other people's badges but then at
e3 they were checking id last year
and they did it the very day we were
finally doing the indie mix
so him and i like
last minute got in touch with all these
people got all these badges printed up
and we
and every single developer who was lined
up to be on our stage ended up being on
our stage
it's something i haven't talked about so
it's kind of cool to talk about but like
yeah he was like so helpful and all that
like he was definitely a big part of
that and like
just i don't know after that i was like
i feel like we're a lot closer now
after that with all this through some
stuff it's a cool morning
i'll put in work to make i remember that
because you were drifting i was like
i was like i'm just gonna go i'm gonna
leave yeah so shouts out to both of
y'all man
when we when we started doing play for
all um justin was one of the first
people to
just hit us up and get on board um
with like the endemic stuff and the
gorilla collective stuff and we kind of
uh partnered with them through larian
and you know the bottles gate thing and
it started off with let's talk about
harian um and then eventually just
became the whole
like indie you know uh the guerrilla
collective stuff and
he was just like super open breaking
down everything that was gonna happen
like moment by moment like helped us
it's we
have to often juggle and beg people and
really force their hand and giving us
assets and that kind of stuff and
information
he just like trusts us completely and
gave us everything and
and like then he put on their own show
and
it was just like impressive like unique
show
um so like yeah justin one of the like
smartest and
like hardest working people in the
industry huge shout out to him
well guy that's that's my guy i want to
shout out some donations that we got
um so i might have missed this but matt
hawking gave another ten dollars and
said nice work everyone thank you so
much matt
5 55 from anonymous thank you so much
anonymous these are
my names direct relief direct relief
thank you so much and our very own
richie bracamonte 20.69
because happy to be a part of this team
happy and proud to be part of this team
thank you richie you're amazing couldn't
have done it
for being in the chat all the time over
on black lives matter uh david trang
another ten dollars thank you david
you've been giving a lot as well
thank you so much shout out to you david
and
alessandro barbossa our very own fifty
dollars to black lives matter
thank you alessandro thank you alexandra
again another member of the editorial
team that has just been put in work
lately a little hero time i'm gonna go
to you i've been your kind of
gaming highlights uh so jake covered
cyberpunk and
very uh expertly avoided the fact that
he uh
publicly said that he was excited for an
anime um
hold on to him there oh don't worry the
chat saw that in the
day and i'm like what about
jake officially are we but my highlight
has
definitely got to be demon souls
remaster yeah um
i wish i could have heard you when that
happened i wish i mean like michael
michael and i got it like
i know chad i think chastity you tweeted
like you could hear him like through the
walls i
wish oh i wish you could have seen that
that was the weirdest sound
you said you wouldn't tell anyone
but yeah that was like i i had it's one
of those things where you know
we're doing what we do like we start to
hear whispers about things
and that was one whisper i heard very
very long time ago and i was like
i'm gonna do my absolute best to avoid
any sort of follow-ups about this
and i very carefully avoided what
bluepoint was doing the entire time
knowing that at some point there was a
chance of demon souls appearing and then
it appeared and i
destroyed my hand and screamed and
and like it was destroyed my hand
because i smacked it on a
on a desk because yeah not for other
reasons
um uh well
i made the sushi face so i needed that
um
but yeah that was like unreal and like
it just felt like a game
that i like it's it's a game that i
really need
like right now just because so those
games are they have a special place
in in my life and the the purpose they
serve is
incredibly unique and you know as the
maiden in black says they need something
now
so the world can be mended um
very good well all right we're kind of
winding down here
but uh a couple of final shout outs so
we actually have a store that launched
uh this week i'm bringing it up in that
kind of way because
if you buy anything from the store all
proceeds are gonna go to black lives
matter and to direct relief
um just wanted to oh look at tay look at
this switching on the floor perfect
perfect so yeah we've got some cool
stuff in there um we're still raising
money
um i think we've all said you know like
how proud we all are of for working on
this and you know our thanks to everyone
who's donated watch the streams
participate in streams
uh we have an exciting bit of news um
i guess from from viacom cbs who is
obviously a parent company
who who wants to announce this one i
mean
i can i think we can all do it
first of all i want to shout out like a
couple people for actually
this was something we wanted we asked
for but like a few people really chased
it down to us
randy who's our editor-in-chief randolph
ramsey
really pushed on this chris beaumont who
is you know head of video
and really pushed on this and then ben
um who was kind of like instrumental
in ben howard and making sure that we
actually
managed to make it happen and what they
made happen was like we asked for
um viacom cbs to kind of pitch in some
money to you know should do its part and
support us and and the causes that we're
raising money for and
it absolutely has is donating a total of
a hundred thousand dollars
to charities which is an unreal amount
we were we thought maybe we'd get 10k
album or something like that
but like and ben i think i i can
comfortable in quoting him and he was
you know he said
that everyone was the company was so
proud of
you know the effort that everyone on
this team has put in that they wanted to
make sure that they were
you know as as the internet and siam
says you know keep the energy going
so a hundred thousand dollars in total
50 000 going to direct relief
and then 50 000 going to black lives
matter which
i mean that alone is 100k that we've
raised
um through the generosity of our
corporate overlords
but on top of that you know between the
donations that um
the you know the people the community
and the folks that have been coming on
the stream and their communities
and then our own you know team teammates
and colleagues and then
that's our their donations are being
matched by cbs as well
and viacom cbs like i think that's
coming to close to 50k
as well so in total we've raised around
50 150k for both black lives matter
and uh direct relief which is an
absolutely ridiculous amount that we
never thought we would do
but we did it and wha what a
an incredible achievement
i was good at the 100k
well i saw him making that on the fly
yeah
well played it's like that out in the in
slack yesterday
and yes yeah i mean like it kind of goes
back to what we were saying before is
that
we work for a place that's you know
having a moment and like drawing a line
in the sand and
showing where where it stands and you
know
obviously all the people that work there
and i'm really yeah
proud to be involved in this whole thing
working with all you guys and
chatting with the community uh like jake
said earlier please
message one of us i mean jake you and i
tam do you have your dm's open
yep my dm's are open dm's are open
about the discord too actually is that
uh the mods are starting a game jam
yeah so if that's something you're
interested in like definitely
hit us up about it because it's like the
theme is gamespot so
i didn't we didn't even pick that theme
yeah yeah
and then i just go back and see the
theme is gamespot and like all right
awesome
yeah it's really cool and um
yeah thank you everyone who's been on
this i almost said journey with us
it's ongoing look of course we're not
done yet like you're
still we're not done yeah it's still
xbox it's still ubisoft it's still
devolver
and the donation links are all all
remaining live so
all link uh yeah all of that is going
towards the charities until the end of
august
so plenty of time uh if you want to get
some
sick apparel i know kurt you've got the
skateboard to the skate deck
should i go get it yeah you should
because there's a giant picture of
kurt diving through tam's floor
in the middle of the stadium i'm just
crying
the entire time
just just show them the part where
you're making tam crunch
ruining tannins
[Laughter]
here's me smashing through the floor
into tam's room
which is totally messed up because that
would imply that i beat him at a video
game which is
not something that can happen also
in a flooded bathroom right now also
jake can we talk about this for a second
you're like sitting and playing a video
game with your pants
my favorite one on this my favorite one
on this is chastity who's eating i got
an
entire chicken a whole chicken i do that
i will go but also buy an entire
rotisserie chicken and not share it with
anybody
but it's just fast this is it uh
it's legit i was actually gonna consider
trying to skate this but i don't think i
can bring myself to do it
well no also because the wheel would go
like right through me so
put it on oh my god
you're good um
all right let's let's kind of wrap this
up um
thank you to everyone who's been
watching and like donating in the chat
um it's gonna be weird not kind of
finishing videos by saying that
anymore yeah but um you know
you'll know you know where to find us
let's go around the room chastity
i'm at chapter city underscore v on
twitter uh
michael you can find me and all of my
[ __ ] at michael p hyam
um on twitter my dms are open but i have
no decision making power whatsoever at
gamespot so
uh don't come at me with any suggestions
but i'll put in a good word for you
okay i'm current devina at curt
underscore in davina my dms are also
open
you can message me about whatever your
heart desires lemon bar recipes
so just just ask me about that
yeah just give me give me your limbo
recipes jake
uh you can find me at jacob deck and i
am now accepting last of the spoilers
that wasn't for a while
but people can spoil that game for me
now if they want
tay
who knows what he's doing oh here he is
okay hopefully this works
don't worry about me my dms are open but
i can't help you with the job
i can help point you to where you could
get a job
[Laughter]
surprisingly there has been if you look
at chat a lot
every one of the conference streams i've
like replied to people
with it at least has game spot because
i'm just logged in because i have to
turn on the streams that way
they always ask how do we get to get how
do we get a job i'm like you can go to
cvsinteractive.com
because i can't do anything i'm just
saying that
anyways start a youtube channel yeah
ambitious anyways coming back to lucy
i'm at it
uh i'm at tomorrow h you can message me
about bloodborne
i'm at lucy james games you can message
me about
red dead too because i'm all about that
red dead online life now or overwatch
or also just to get an invite to the
discord which you should because it's a
great place
yeah thank you so much everyone i hope
you have a great weekend
we will see you tomorrow for devolver
digital and sunday for ubisoft forward
and then i think on the 23rd for xbox
and you know we'll be
all over all the time anyway
bye oh snap peace bye thank you so much
[Music]
foreign